The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
YEN-JIE LEE: So welcome
back again to 8.03.
Today, my plan is to continue
the discussion of the two
string system, which we were
working really hard last time
but we sort of run out of time.
So we didn't have time to
enjoy what we have done, right?
So today we are going to
discuss all the outcome
of that calculation.
And so we will start to discuss
more examples which can be
described by the wave equation.
Today we are going to talk
about another example, which
is sound waves.
It's a very exciting topic.
And afterwards, we will
start the discussion
about electromagnetic waves.
So this is the wave equation
which we have been using,
and over the last
few lectures, we
have been discussing two
specials kinds of solutions--
the normal modes,
which is actually
standing waves in the
end, which we identified,
and the progressing
wave solution, which
is very powerful in
describing the phenomena which
we are familiar with.
Last time, in the
end of the lecture,
we were discussing about
an interesting example,
which involves two
strings in the system.
One essentially in the left-hand
side have mass per unit length,
rho l equals to rho 1, and
right-hand side one is thicker,
and therefore, the mass
per unit length, rho,
is larger, which
is called rho 2.
What we did last
time is to assume
that we have a progressing
wave, which essentially
going into this--
which essentially first
initiated in the left-hand side
string and it's going towards
the boundary of the two
systems--
the more massive one and
the less massive one.
And see what is going to happen.
And what we actually tried
to describe last time
is that we actually define
incident wave described
by this fi function,
transmitting wave, ft,
and the refractive wave, fr.
By using boundary conditions
which we described last time
we can conclude
that there's a fixed
relation between the three
waves equation-- wave functions.
What we actually
concluded that last time
is that fr is proportional to
fi, which is the incident wave
function, by some constant,
which is called r.
And what is r?
As we solved last time, it's
V2 minus V1 over V1 plus V2,
which are the velocities of
the first and second string.
And the transmitted wave, ft,
is actually also proportional
to the incident wave.
And the coefficient--
we call it tau--
to describe the amplitude
of the transmitted wave.
So what we can do
is the variance.
So we actually discussed
two examples last time,
plugging in V1 and V2.
And there are two more
examples we can actually
make use of this equation we
obtained last time to discuss
what would be the
physics outcome
of this kind of situation.
So the first example which
we can actually discuss
is that, OK, now I
have this string.
Assume, though, they're
connected to a wall.
So this time we can say,
oh, wait, wait, wait, wait
a second.
There's only one
string now, right?
But last time we were
solving two strings, right?
But what I'm doing now
is to treat the wall
as if it's a string.
But this wall is really massive.
Therefore, the rho l, or
the mass per unit length,
is really large.
OK.
It goes to infinity.
If that's the case, if
you're set this idea--
this is still a
two string system--
then I can now go
ahead and calculate
what will be the velocity.
The velocity V2 goes to 0.
Then I can go ahead and
plug into my equations.
So we spend a lot of
time in the last lecture
to obtain those equations.
And we will find that
if I have V2 goes to 0,
I have r equal to minus 1.
And the tau, which
is actually related
to the amplitude of
the transmitted wave,
is equal to 0, which you
can see from this equation.
What does that mean?
That means once we
solve that question,
we also know what would be the
outcome of this experiment,
this physical situation.
When we have a string
attached to a wall
and we have an incident wave,
as a function of time, what
is going to happen afterward
is that this wave is
going to propagate and
hit the wall and get
refracted completely.
The amplitude ratio is minus 1.
Therefore, all the
energy is refracted
by the wall in this highly
idealized situation.
So that's kind of interesting.
The second example is
also very interesting.
So if you have a string
attached to a massive ring,
and this ring can go up and down
freely without any friction,
you can again say, no, no, no,
this is again a single string
system, right?
But what I'm going to
argue now is that, OK,
there's another string which is
so light mass per unit length
is close to 0.
So it is actually in the air.
If I do that, what
is going to happen?
The rho l is going to
go to the limit of 0,
because the right-hand side
you almost cannot see it.
And the V2, which
is the velocity
of the transmitted
wave, goes to infinity.
If that's the case,
you can then again,
plugging into this equation
we obtained, and then
you conclude that r
would be equal to 1
and tau will be equal to 2.
So what does that mean?
This means that if you
have this end, which
is the open end,
attached to a ring which
can move up and down, then
you get that refraction.
The amplitude of
the refractive wave
doesn't change, because
i is equal to 1.
So it's still in the positive
direction we defined.
But now, it goes backward.
Again, all the energy
is actually refracted,
as you can see
from this equation.
But the curious case is that--
the strangest thing is
that the tau is equal to 2.
That's kind of strange, right?
Tau is equal to 2.
What does that mean?
That means you are going to
predict a transmitted wave
with amplitude exactly the
two times the incident wave,
and it's going to be propagating
in the right-hand side
and the speed goes to infinity.
What does that mean?
Does that mean the
energy is not conserved?
Have we found the cure
of the energy crisis?
Because now-- I can actually
take all those energy.
I can design this thing,
and then this thing
will bounce around
all over the place.
And that is going
to emit energy.
Oh my god, we solve
all the problem.
You should be really
excited about it, right?
No?
But unfortunately,
rho l goes to 0.
So there's actually nothing
oscillating out of this system.
So therefore, there is no
additional energy radiated out
of this system.
Too bad.
Go back to work.
All right.
So that's actually what
we discussed last time,
and I hope that
complete the loop.
And today, before we
actually move to sound wave,
I would like to talk
about, very briefly,
harmonic progressing waves.
So now, we can see that harmonic
progressing wave looks really
beautiful, as you can see here.
And it can be described by a
cosine kx minus omega t plus 5.
5 is actually the face.
And you can always write
it in different forms.
And since we have
learned how to describe
in general the progressing
wave, this is just to remind you
that, OK, there's
no proper notion
to describe a harmonic
progressing wave.
So since we have
learned about waves,
which involve oscillation
in the transverse direction.
So basically, we
always say, OK, things
are oscillating up and
down in the case of string.
Before I start, though,
the sound wave, there's
a different kind of wave
which we can also see
very often in the daily life.
This is called
longitudinal waves.
For example, I can have a spring
wave, and I can actually--
imagine I have a spring wave.
And I can do this.
I oscillate in the
horizontal direction.
Then that can produce
displacement with respect
to the equilibrium position.
And this kind of behavior
is like a density wave.
We call it longitudinal waves.
This is exactly what is
happening with sound wave.
So what is actually sound wave?
Essentially, a collection
or motion of air molecules.
And they are actually
oscillating back and forth.
And we may use that to extend
energy all over the place.
And today we are going to
discuss the sound wave.
And by the way,
just for simplicity,
because drawing all those dots
really take a lot of time.
So what we sometimes
do is that, OK,
we can now draw the pressure,
the amplitude of the pressure,
or the amplitude
of the displacement
of individual molecules
in the discussion
as a function of time.
So if we draw the amplitude
as a function of time
or as a function of
location, then it
looks exactly the same as
what we discussed before
for the transverse waves.
So just some clarification.
It's not like the molecules
are going up and down.
They are going back and
forth, and it's just a matter
presenting that these are.
So this is actually an
example of a travelling wave
in the longitudinal direction.
And you can see
that it is actually
the density which is actually
changing as a function of time.
And as you can
see, it's actually
traveling at a fixed speed and
going in the right direction
of the blackboard.
So those being said,
we can actually
get started with a
concrete example.
So I would like to discuss
with you now a system,
which is like you have a tube,
with cross section area, A.
So A is actually the area
of the cross section.
And I can now wonder--
now the physics question I'm
asking is, what would be the--
what would be the behavior
of the air inside this tube?
So before I go ahead
and solve this problem,
I need to define and give
you some more information
about this tube and also the
condition or the environment
this tube is living in.
So the first information
I would like to give you
is that the pressure,
the room pressure,
is actually P0 in this example.
So the P0 is actually
the room pressure.
And I can now define coordinates
is the x direction is actually
in the horizontal
direction pointing
to the right-hand side.
And now, I can actually try to
describe a small unit volume
inside the tube by location x.
And the width of this
volume, I call it delta x.
And if I go ahead and prepare
this system and at time, t,
something is happening
to this system--
so now, you need length.
You need volume,
I was discussing.
This get displaced with respect
to the equilibrium position.
So that means, assuming
that something happened
at the t equal to t, the left
inside edge of the volume
is shifted toward a positive
direction, which is described
by wave function psi x.
And the position of
the right-hand side
edge of this volume is shifted
to side x plus delta x.
So something happened
to this system.
We can also say
that-- we can also
describe this system, the
pressure of this system,
by P function.
P of x is actually
equal to P0, which
is actually room pressure--
P0 is the baseline
room pressure--
plus some kind of displacement
in pressure, psi P.
So now we describe the pressure
acting on the left inside edge
of the small unit volume,
and the right-hand side,
you can also do the same thing.
P of x plus delta x will
be equal to P0 plus psi P,
describing the
displacement or how
offset the pressure is as a
function of x but now evaluated
at x plus delta x.
So once we have all of
those elements defined--
these are essentially
just a copy
of what I have in the slide
and those are a reminder here--
now, we can actually calculate
the motion of all the molecules
in this volume, because I have
pressure, I have displacement.
The displacement is
described by psi,
end position is described by
psi, the change in pressure
is described by psi P. And
now I can go ahead and apply,
for example, Newton's law.
Then I can calculate
what would be
the acceleration for all the
molecules inside this volume.
But wait a second.
That sounds all great,
but I don't know yet
how to relate pressure
and the volume,
because pressure is
actually expressed by psi P
and the volume is
related to psi.
I need to know is actually
the relation between pressure
and the displacement
or pressure between psi
so that I can make progress.
So that this actually the
main discussion which I would
like to do in this lecture.
So given those
information, I can now
calculate what is actually the
change in this little volume.
So I can calculate
the change in volume,
which is described by
delta V. But delta V
can be actually calculated
by a, which is actually
the area of the
cross section, times
psi x plus delta
xt minus psi xt.
So basically, just calculate how
much the boundary is actually
displaced.
And if we always take very
small amplitude approximation,
then basically
this expression is
roughly equal to A partial
psi partial x times delta x,
where the delta x is
really very small.
So a very small volume
I was talking about.
And I can also
calculate the pressure.
What is the pressure difference?
The pressure difference
is between the pressure
acting in the left-hand side
edge and the pressure which
is acting on the
right-hand side edge.
So I can now calculate
pressure difference,
delta P. Delta P would be minus
psi P x plus delta x t plus psi
P x t.
So basically, one is
essentially the pressure
pushing the body in
the right-hand side.
The other one
essentially pushing it
in the left-hand side direction.
Again, I can take very
small delta x approximation.
And basically, what
you are going to get
is minus partial psi
P partial x delta x.
So we have prepared all
of those information
about volume and the pressure.
As I mentioned before,
the big question
which we would like
to ask is, how do I
relate pressure and the volume
so that I can make progress?
If I can relate
pressure and volume,
then I can know
what is the relation
between psi P and the psi.
Then I can ask you to
make use of Newton's Law.
Then I can calculate the
resulting equation of motion.
So there's two possible
interesting scenarios
which we can relate
temperature-- so sorry,
relate pressure and the volume.
The first one was
proposed by Newton.
Newton said that, OK, this
is an interesting phenomena.
In my opinion, although
you actually displaced
this volume--
make the displacement for
those molecules in the tube--
but because the heat was
conducted from one region
to the other region,
all those regions
are connected to each other.
And the speed of this
heat transfer is so fast.
It's really fast, like instant.
This heat is actually
transferred from one direction
to the other--
one position to
the other position.
Therefore, over the
course of this evolution,
the temperature
should be unchanged.
No matter what you do to
the air inside the tube,
the temperature
should be unchanged,
because Newton thinks
that heat should be--
the speed of the
heat distribution
is really, really fast.
Much faster than
all those vibration
happening in the tube.
If that is the case--
that is the case--
then that means we
can use ideal gas law.
P times V is equal to nRT.
I hope that you have learned
this before in 8.01 and 8.02.
If that's the case, that means--
so all those things
are constant,
because we assume that
temperature is unchanged.
Therefore, the right-hand side
is essentially a constant.
Therefore, P times V would
be some kind of constant.
The V would be
proportional to 1/P.
So that essentially
is the first idea,
which is coming from
Newton, in order
to relate pressure
and the volume.
The second idea is
coming from Laplace.
Laplace says, OK, he
has a different opinion
on this matter.
He think that this essentially
is an adiabatic process.
What does that mean?
That means the heat flow
from the compressed region
to the other region
is really negligible,
because the oscillation
is really fast
and the speed of the
transfer of the heat
is really slow compared to the
time scale of the oscillation.
Therefore, in
Laplace's opinion, he
thinks that the whole
process is adiabatic process.
If that's the case, which
I will show you later,
that means you have this
relation between pressure
and the volume.
P times V to the gamma.
Gamma essentially
related to the decrease
of freedom of the molecule,
which we will discuss later
in the class.
This would be equal to constant.
So the very interesting
thing of this lecture
is that we are going to be able
to test which one is correct.
You will be able to see if
Newton win or Laplace win.
So as I mentioned
before, one is assuming
the heat transfer, the speed
of the heat propagation,
is really, really much larger
than the speed of oscillation.
The other viewpoint
from Laplace is
that the heat flow is
actually really negligible
compared to the oscillation
we are talking about here.
And now, as usual, I would
like to have a vote now.
How many of you
support Newton's idea?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7, 8, 9, 10, 11--
so 15 of you vote for Newton.
How many of you saying
Laplace is correct?
How about the others?
OK, very good.
So we have a majority of you
support the idea of Laplace,
and some of you
actually support Newton.
And we are going to see what is
going to happen in the lecture
today.
So let's go ahead and
apply these two ideas.
So PV gamma equal to constant.
So in the case if ideal gas
law, gamma is equal to 1.
Therefore, I just have to work
on these function of form.
And then also later
we will figure out
what is gamma all together.
So that's consider
only small vibration.
Small vibration means--
small vibration means
that I have psi P,
which essentially,
from this definition,
psi P is the change
in pressure with respect
to the room pressure, P0.
So psi P, assuming that's
much, much smaller than P0.
And also, I assume that the
changing volume, delta V, which
I calculated there,
is much, much smaller
than P0, which is essentially
the original volume
of this little area--
original volume of this
area I was working here.
All right.
So that's the two assumption.
Before I change the position of
the boundary, which essentially
is the upper graph, if I change
anything, I have P0 V0 gamma.
This is equal to some constant,
C. And gamma can be equal to 1
so that you have ideal gas law.
After the vibration
initially happened,
after the wall's initially
displaced from the equilibrium
position, what I'm
going to get is--
I will have P plus delta P times
V0 plus delta V to the gamma.
This is equal to C.
So based on those,
actually I have already
calculated delta P and delta V.
So in this case, this delta P
should be--
OK, this is actually
not the delta P
I was talking about there, so
I should change it to delta P.
Because that's,
essentially, the difference
between the resulting pressure
and the original pressure.
It's not the difference between
the left-hand side pressure
and the right-hand
side pressure,
which essentially
is showing there.
So this delta P, which
I have already defined,
essentially called
psi P. Therefore, I
will derive this
to be P plus psi P.
And I can now also copy these.
You are going to get V0
plus delta V to the gamma.
And this is equal to C.
So as I mentioned before, I'm
considering small vibration.
Delta V is much,
much smaller than V0.
Therefore, this expression
can be written as P--
sorry, this should be P0.
I'm making some mistake here.
This expression should be
written as P0 plus psi P.
V0 to the gamma.
1 plus gamma delta V over
V0, because delta V is much,
much smarter than V0.
Can everybody follow?
So here I will already take
small vibration approximation.
And basically, I can
now rewrite this thing.
I just expend all those terms.
Basically, I call this
equation number two.
Equation number two will become
P0 V0 gamma plus gamma delta V
V0 gamma to the minus
1 P0 plus psi P V0
to the gamma plus gamma delta V
psi P V0 to the gamma minus 1.
So there's no magic.
Essentially, it's just
expanding these terms.
Then, basically, you are
going to get four terms.
And basically, if you do
write down the equation number
two especially,
that is essentially
what you are going to get.
So we are making
progress, and we
would like to simplify things.
And you can quickly
identify the hardest term,
P0 V0 to the gamma.
I know what is the
value of that, right?
That essentially is
the original situation,
and that is
essentially equal to C.
Let's take a look
at also this term.
This term is
proportional to what?
Proportional to delta V, which
is a very small quantity,
and proportional to psi P, which
is another very small quantity.
Therefore, taking a small
vibration approximation,
I would just simply
ignore this term.
Is everybody following?
All right.
So this term, this
original term,
is equal to C based
on this expression.
So we start from the system
before the vibration happened.
After the vibration happened
there's a change in pressure,
there's a change in delta
V. But if you multiply PV
to the gamma, this
expression is still
equal to C, some
kind of constant.
And then, now I do small
vibration approximation,
and I drop the term which
is actually proportional
to delta V times psi P.
And basically what I get
is that C is equal to
C plus gamma delta P V0
gamma minus 1 P0 plus
psi P V0 to the gamma.
This term, these two
constants cancel.
And now, I can actually
move one of the terms
to the left-hand side.
Then basically, what
I am going to get
is psi P V0 to the gamma would
be equal to minus gamma delta V
gamma 0 gamma to the--
V0 to the gamma
minus 1 times P0.
We can't immediately
cancel V0 to the gamma.
Therefore, what are
we going to get?
I'm getting psi P would be
equal to minus gamma P0 over V0
delta V. Everybody following?
So this is essentially
the expression.
And we also know
why essentially is
delta V. Based on
this expression,
delta V is essentially A
partial psi partial x delta x,
if we look at the upper
board, which we actually just
derived a moment ago.
Therefore, I can write, replace
delta V by that expression.
Then basically what I get
is psi P would be equal
to minus gamma P0 A delta
x divided by V0 partial psi
partial x.
I'm just plugging in the
expression for delta V
to that equation.
A lot of mathematics,
but all of them
should be pretty
straightforward.
You don't actually have to
copy because all of them
are in the lecture note.
OK?
All right.
So here, you can
see I can, again,
simplify this expression.
A is actually the cross
section of the tube,
and delta x is the width
in the x direction.
So A times delta x is just V0.
Oh, very good!
I get this very simple
expression, minus gamma P0
partial psi partial x.
So we have achieved our goal
to simplify the expression
and to find the relation
between psi P and the psi.
That's actually what originally
we were hoping to do,
and we have achieved that.
And I call it equation
number three here.
Don't forget what is
psi and psi P. Psi
P is the amount of
change in pressure,
and the psi is the amount of
displacement of the wall--
of the molecule in the volume.
So now, I'm really
close to my solution,
because now I can now
calculate the force acting
on this little
volume, because now I
know what is the pressure.
So what is the F total?
The F total is
essentially delta P,
which is the
difference in pressure
from the left-hand side end
compared to the right-hand side
end.
So that's what we
calculated before.
Now this, A partial psi
P partial x delta x.
We also know what
would be the mass.
We know that the little mass
in this volume, delta m,
will be equal to rho, which
is the density of the air,
times A, which is the cross
section, times delta x.
That will give you
the little area, V0.
So rho times A times delta
x will be your delta m.
We are almost there.
I have the m, I have the
force, what kind of law
do I need to use to get
my equation of motion?
AUDIENCE: Newton's law.
YEN-JIE LEE:
Newton's law, right?
Newton's law.
So F is equal to
m times a, right?
So therefore, I
can now calculate
and essentially I can now plug
in rho times A times delta x.
What is A?
A is essentially psi double-dot.
That's essentially describing
the displacement with respect
to the equilibrium position.
And now I know this is equal to
force, which is A times delta x
partial psi P partial x.
And you can see that both
ends you have a delta x.
So I can cancel that.
Both ends you have an A,
so now I can cancel that.
Then basically you get
rho psi double-prime.
This is equal to
partial psi P partial x.
From the beginning we're talking
about the relation between psi
P, the displacement in
pressure, and psi, how much
the molecules are displaced.
And then we have
the solution here.
If you assume the
relation which was
given by Newton or by
Laplace, basically, you
can conclude that this
would be equal to gamma
P0 partial square psi
P partial x square.
All right.
And I can now put
all the constants
to the right-hand side.
Basically, what you get
is psi double-prime.
So here it should be partial
square psi partial x square,
because I replaced psi P by psi.
And I must miss one--
I must miss one
negative sign somewhere.
AUDIENCE: Over there.
YEN-JIE LEE: Where?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YEN-JIE LEE: Oh,
this essentially--
there's a minus
sign there, right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
On the left side.
YEN-JIE LEE: On
the left-hand side.
Yeah.
That's right.
AUDIENCE: Oh, no.
There should be A. That's wrong.
YEN-JIE LEE: Yes, you are right.
And the minus sign
should belong there.
So that actually--
sorry for that.
So there should be
a minus sign here.
And there should be
And after I plug in
equation number three,
then I get psi double-prime
equal to gamma P0
over rho partial square
psi partial x square.
Any other problems you find?
Not yet?
OK.
So look at this equation.
Oh my god!
What is this equation?
AUDIENCE: Wave.
YEN-JIE LEE: Wave equation.
Again.
Wave equation.
You can say that, huh,
I'm not surprised,
because this system
is used so many times.
I have learned
this so many times,
but I am still
surprised that this
is so identical to
the physics which
we have been studying
for the strings
for over the few lectures.
So that's very nice.
And now, the question
we have an answer
is that, OK, what
essentially is gamma?
What is essentially gamma?
So gamma, in the case of
the adiabatic process,
gamma is actually equals to
alpha plus 1 minus alpha.
And alpha is related to the
number of degrees of freedom.
So if you haven't
done this before,
I have a concrete proof
of the adiabatic process.
And this is actually
coming from the first law
of thermodynamics.
And basically, you will
be able to conclude
that gamma will be equal to
alpha plus 1 divided by alpha.
The value of alpha--
the value you get
for alpha is related
to how many degrees of
freedom you can actually
have in this system.
For example, if I have a system
which is made of atomic gas--
so there's only one
atom in a molecule--
and basically you have
3 degrees of freedom.
So you can move this thing
in the horizontal direction.
You can move this atom upside
down or back and forth.
So there are three
degrees of freedom.
And if you calculate alpha,
that will give you 3/2.
And basically, if you calculate
gamma according to the equation
you are going to get 1.67.
On the other hand, if
you have atomic gas,
that means you have
more degrees of freedom.
So basically, you have
not only the translation
of degrees of freedom--
the three ones which are
identical to the atomic gas--
you can also have two
rotational degrees of freedom.
So you can have these two
atoms rotating like this,
you can have that
rotating like that.
The trickiest thing is this one
vibration degree of freedom,
as you learned from the
couple equations before.
But this one, very trickily,
is not excited at all
at low temperature.
You have to go to really,
really super high temperature
so that this actually contribute
to the overall degrees
of freedom.
So therefore, you have a
total of available degrees
of freedom of 5.
And if you calculate the gamma,
you basically will get 1.4.
So let's now
calculate what will be
the resulting speed of light.
Sorry, no.
Not speed of light.
The speed of sound So if the
temperature remain unchanged,
if you take this equation
here, this is a wave equation.
Therefore, I know how to
calculate the speed of sound.
The speed of sound
will be equal to--
P will be equal
to the square root
of gamma P0 divided by rho.
So I have figured out the rho
and the room pressure for you.
So the P0 will be 10 to
5 kilogram ms squared,
and the rho will
be equal to 1.2.
Rho is actually the
density of the air.
It's essentially 1.2
kilogram per meter cubed.
If I have a gamma equal to 1,
which is the case for ideal gas
law temperature unchanged,
if I calculate the resulting
speed of sound you are
going to get something
like 389 meters per second.
So that's the
prediction for Newton.
And the second
case, if we have--
if we are believing what
Laplace actually said,
the heat flow is really,
really negligible
compared with the
speed of oscillation,
then we have, as we
discussed last slide,
gamma would be equal to 1.4.
Therefore, you would be able
to calculate the resulting
speed of sound, and
that is actually 342.
So those are the predictions.
And what I'm going to do
now is to really demonstrate
that we can actually measure the
speed of sound in front of you.
So the first thing
which I will need to do
is to switch so that
you can see the camera.
And now, I have a set up here.
Basically, this set up
is like the following.
So basically, very similar
to the setup we have here.
But at one end, we
actually have a speaker
which produced sound wave.
So this is essentially
what we have.
This is the tube,
and we have, one end,
there's a speaker attached to
here, produce a sound wave.
And basically, the amplitude
will look like this.
So basically, this will create
some kind of standing wave
inside the tube.
And I have another device,
which is actually a microphone.
A microphone is connected
to this scope, which shows
you the amplitude of the--
basically, the amplitude
measured by this microphone.
And you see that if I move
this, as a function of position
you see that the am is changing.
It's getting smaller when it is
actually hitting the note here,
because here there's almost
no oscillation in the air.
Therefore, you will
measure a very small signal
at that position.
And if you continue
to move, then you
can see that, aha, I
move away from the note,
therefore I see
some kind of maxima.
Then, I see that this
amplitude is dropping again.
If I continue-- if I continue,
then say that, aha, again,
this amplitude is increasing
to a very large value.
Then it decreases to a
minima around the note.
So what I going to
do now is to measure
the distance between notes.
And since the sound waves, which
I actually put into the system,
have a frequency of--
let me see.
The frequency I put in--
the frequency I put in
is actually 1 kilohertz.
With the location of the note,
I can know what will be, what?
What will be the wavelengths
of the sound waves.
So therefore, I can now
measure the distance
between those three notes.
Then I would be able to
measure the wavelengths.
know who is correct--
if Newton is correct
or Laplace is correct.
So let's do that.
So let me find the first minima.
So the first minima
is around 64.
64 centimeter.
And you can see that.
Say stop when you see that
it's reaching the minima again.
Stop.
OK, very good.
So this is actually the
first note, the location
of the first note,
and I was trying
to find the next note
so that I can actually
readout the wavelengths.
Now, this will increase again.
And reach-- stop?
Is that a stop sign?
OK, very good.
All right.
So I get the value, which
is actually 30 centimeter.
So now I can calculate
what would be the lambda.
The lambda is
actually 64 minus 30.
Then, what I get
is 34 centimeters.
And if I calculate the velocity
of the sound wave, then
basically I have F times
lambda, and that will give you--
this is actually equal
to 0.34 centimeter.
So that would give you
340 meters per second.
Oh my god.
This is so close to the
prediction of Laplace.
First of all, this is amazing.
Why?
Because with this looks
really crappy thing,
I can measure speed of sound.
Secondly, ooh, the
measurement is really great.
It match within 1%.
You guys did a good
job of stopping me.
Very nice.
And finally, very unfortunately,
people who voted for Newton
is wrong.
So what happened
is the following.
What happened is
that Newton actually
assumed that the speed of
propagation of the heat
is really fast, but
actually that's not true.
Because, for example, I'm
standing here and heating up
the air.
In the last few lecture,
I even heat up the air
by some kind of fire
in front of you.
But you don't feel
the heat, right?
So the heat propagation is
really not really, really fast
compared to the
speed of vibration.
The vibration is really
quick, because it's really
vibrating up and down
1,000 times per second.
So that means what is
actually much more reasonable
is to describe this process
is adiabatic process.
So we will take a
five minute break
here so that we
can take questions,
and then we'll come
back at the 39.
So welcome back, everybody.
So we can see that
from the last--
so from the discussion
we had before the break,
we see that the sound wave can
be described by something which
we are now very familiar with--
the wave equation.
And also, we know what is the
speed of the sound, which,
based on this wave
equation, the speed of sound
is actually equal to square
root of gamma P0 over rho.
So gamma is actually
obtained from this discussion
of how many degrees
of freedom we have.
So the first case
we discussed is,
if you have a single atom
of which you make your air,
then basically the gamma
is actually higher.
On the other hand, if
you have diatomic gas,
then the gamma is
actually slightly smaller.
It's 1.4.
So what would happen if I
change the air in my lung
to monatomic atom?
So what is going to happen
is that the speed of sound
is going to be increased.
The speed of sound
will increase.
And I have a fixed
sized of lung.
I didn't increase
the size of my lung.
Therefore, the frequency
of my sound will what?
Will increase.
So how about we do that
experiment and see if it works?
So here, I have a balloon
here, which is full of helium.
Let me see if it works.
I'm not sure if it will
work, but let's see.
Fingers crossed.
We'll see what happens.
Now I'm going to do a
measure of operation
to replace all the air
in my lung by this.
Does my sound change?
[LAUGHTER]
No?
Didn't work.
Let me do that again.
I speak more aggressive.
[LAUGHTER]
Did you hear any difference?
No.
(HIGH PITCHED) Any difference?
Works?
Works now?
Very good.
Maybe we should use some--
maybe we should use
that sound to go over
all the lecture, right?
It's a very
dangerous experiment,
because you are replacing
all the air in your lung.
So you may choke.
Fortunately, I survived this
experiment and hope you enjoy.
[APPLAUSE]
What happened is the following.
So basically-- basically,
the gamma becomes large.
Therefore, the speed of sound
in my lung becomes large.
Therefore, the
frequency of my sound
increased and you hear
some really strange sound.
OK, very good.
So before the end,
I would like--
poor Newton.
Before the end, I would like
to discuss with you something
which I hope I would not
see again in the exam
but I saw before.
So if I create a progressing
wave in a single--
in a closed end, open end
tube, this progressing wave
is going to be propagating
at the speed of what?
The speed of what?
AUDIENCE: Sound.
YEN-JIE LEE: Sound, yes.
It's going to be propagating
at the speed of sound,
and you would
reach the boundary.
The question is,
will we see this?
Would this progressing wave just
simply leak out of the tube.
How many of you think
that's going to happen?
I hope I will never see
that again in the exam.
This would never happen.
Why?
That means you will have a super
narrow collimated progressing
wave going straight
out of a tube,
and that will not actually
match the boundary conditions
at the end of the tube.
So that means,
basically, first of all,
there was no refraction.
That means that all the
energy is transferred
outside of the world.
And according to what
we discussed before,
what you would expect is
that, OK, now you suddenly
change to environment which you
have really very large volume.
Therefore, you it will be
very difficult to change
the pressure
outside of the tube.
Because what you are
actually connected to
is a reserve of infinite
number of molecules outside.
It's going to be really
hard to change the pressure.
Therefore, apparently
this behavior
doesn't match the
boundary condition.
And therefore, what
you should expect
is something like this,
which I can show you here.
So in this case, you
have both side opened.
What is going to happen is that
at the boundary-- actually,
it's like the case
of hitting a wall,
because outside of the
tube you have really,
really large volume, huge
amount of air out of it.
Therefore, it's
like hitting a wall.
The amplitude of
the progressing wave
changes sine and goes
back through the tube.
And of course, this system
is actually not perfect.
Therefore, there can
be some leaking out--
some energy leak out of
the tube, which essentially
must be happening, because
we can actually roll the tube
and we can hear the sound.
That is because some
of the sound wave
actually leaks out of the tube.
And this process will
go over and over again.
And this progressing
wave is going
to be going back and
forth, like that.
So I hope that after this
demonstration everybody
will expect that, OK,
this will be not--
the result will be like
this progressing wave
is going to be reflected because
of the boundary condition
and also change sine
in terms of amplitude.
So what we have learned today--
so it's already
close to the end.
We have learned example
of a longitudinal wave
And basically, longitudinal
wave is actually
in the form of density
wave in the example
which we covered today.
And the mathematical
description of the sound wave
is going to be almost
identical to what
we have learned from the
string case, which we actually
discussed last time.
There are two
boundary conditions
which I would like to
briefly discuss before we
end the lecture today.
So in the case of open end,
as we discussed before,
we can have a system
which contains
a closed end and an open end.
What will be the boundary
condition for a closed end?
So the closed end
have a wall here.
Therefore, when you
have your molecule,
the air molecule
oscillating back and forth,
when they are actually close to
the wall, they cannot vibrate.
Why?
Because it's hitting the wall.
It cannot vibrate
so that actually,
the boundary condition
at the closed end,
where you have a wall closing
the tube, is psi equal to 0.
And on the other hand,
if you have an open end--
if you have an open end, that
means outside of the tube
the pressure is equal to what?
It's equal to P0.
The room pressure.
And you have so
many stuff there.
Therefore, it's not
possible to actually change
the pressure dramatically
at the edge of the open end.
Therefore, what will
be the condition?
Psi P. Psi P is again the
displacement with respect
to the room.
Pressure will be equal to 0.
Based on what we
actually have learned
from this expression-- sorry
for that, my finger slipped.
From this expression, psi P is
equal to minus gamma P0 d psi
dx So psi P is proportional
to partial psi partial x.
Therefore, this
boundary condition
actually translates to partial
psi partial x equal to 0.
So this issue looks
really familiar to you,
because in terms of psi, if
you forget about this system,
what those boundary
conditions mean to you
is exactly the same
as you have some kind
of a wall in the left-hand side
and it's connected to a string,
and the right-hand
side of the string
is connected to a massless
ring which can actually
move up and down.
These two systems,
if you actually
don't look at the detail--
only look at the wave functions
and the boundary conditions--
they are identical.
So that's actually the first
lesson we learn from here.
So when I talk about
sound wave or when
you think about
sound wave problem,
there's nothing to
be afraid of anymore,
because that's actually the
same as what we have learned
with wall and a string system.
That's the first
thing we learned.
Secondly, that only works
when I write my wave function
in the form of psi.
So now I can actually
get the first normal mode
would be like this if I
plot psi as a function of x.
The second normal mode--
doesn't surprise you--
will look like this,
et cetera, et cetera.
If I plot psi--
if I plot psi as
a function of x.
On the other hand, we
also know that psi P
is proportional to d psi
partial psi partial x.
Therefore, you can also plot
psi P as a function of x.
Then what you are going to
get is something like this.
In the closed end, the psi P is
actually reaching the maxima,
because it's got the wall.
Therefore, it can
actually produce pressure
on top of the wall.
But you cannot move the position
of all of those molecules
in front of the wall.
Therefore, that makes sense.
You will see exactly in
the opposite direction,
if you plot the amplitude
as a function of x,
you see a picture which
is almost like flipped.
Of course, you can also do the
same thing for the second one.
And basically, what you are
going to get is something like.
The second normal mode,
et cetera, et cetera.
So be careful about the
matching between the boundary
condition obtained from the
tube and string-wall system.
They are identical.
Open corresponds
responds to open,
closed corresponds to
closed when you express
your equation of
motion in terms of psi.
On the other hand, if
you change that to psi P,
then the relation
is actually flipped.
Thank you very much, and I hope
you enjoyed the lecture today.
And I will see you next week.